[موسيقى]
اخبروا العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم
الفلسطينيون يحيون الذكرى السابعه
والاربعين ليوم الارض بتنظيم عدد من
الانشطه والفعاليات حيث انطلقت مسيرات
شعبيه داخل الخط الاخضر شارك فيها الالاف
كم اندلعت مواجهات بين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال على الحدود مع قطاع غزه على وقع
توتر متزايد بين واشنطن وتل ابيب مصادر
قريبه من نتنياهو تؤكد التزام الائتلاف
الحاكم
بتمرير تعديلات القضائيه والتمتاز يعرب
للجزيره عن مخاوفه مما يحدث في اسرائيل
ويدعو مسؤوليها للتوصل الى تسويه تستعيد
الهدوء
محكمه روسيه تقرر حبس مراسل صحيفه
على ذمه التحقيق بعد اتهامات له بالتجسس
الصحيفه نفت الاتهامات واكدت سعيها
للافراج الفوري عنه في حين عبر البيت
الابيض عن قلقه اذا اعتقاله قرش
ودع الامريكيين لمغادره روسيا على الفور
انتاج السودان من القمح يتراجع بنحو 30%
بعد تحول المزارعين الى محاصيل اخرى منظمه
الفاو حذرت من ارتفاع معدلات الفقر وتاثر
الامن الغذائي لملايين السودانيين كما
اكدت احتياج البلاد لاستيراد ثلاثه ملايين
ونصف مليون طن من القمح لسد حاجياتها الى
اللقاء